I did a video recently on the number one
best anti-inflammatory food today we're
going to talk about the number one
inflammatory food on the planet so
there's a lot of confusion in this area
of what causes inflammation you have the
vegans telling you that red meat and
other types of animal products cause
inflammation and then you have the
carnivores over here saying it's the
fiber that's causing inflammation so
they get rid of all the fiber and the
plants and all their inflammation goes
away so this is really confusing the
public like what do you do there's many
plants and herbs that have natural
anti-inflammatories right turmeric and
milk thisle and stingy nettle root and
many other plants have
anti-inflammatories but of course they
also have anti-nutrients right some
people might say plants weren't designed
for us to consume because they don't
want to be eaten but someone could say
the same thing with animals animals
don't want to be eaten too they want to
survive right so there's this big battle
on this fiber right fiber is is it good
is it bad should we consume more of it I
know personally for me when I started
getting rid of the grain fibers and
start consuming more protein especially
for breakfast a lot of my inflammation
and went away but I also consume a lot
of plants and uh doesn't create
inflammation in my gut so why is it that
some people do well on more meat and
maybe other people might do better on
Plants now I'm going to cover this topic
in the relationship to inflammation
because you have people that have
autoimmune diseases and nearly all the
autoimmune diseases start in your gut
you also have a lot of people have
allergies to milk nuts eggs gluten now
there's two really interesting things I
want to just uh mention right off the
bat they're basically two things that we
can't digest humans cannot digest fiber
okay it's non-digestible we don't have
the enzymes to digest fiber and also
glut the protein in grains is the only
protein that we can't digest and now
what about this fiber right do we have a
problem with fiber well some people can
do well with fiber and other people
can't so what breaks down the fiber it's
your microbes so if you were just to do
some research on your own just type in
Google Fiber gut health fiber
inflammation gut inflammation you're
going to just find Fiber is
anti-inflammatory you're going to find
that for so many different research
articles will tell you that but it
doesn't really explain when a carnivore
cuts out the fiber man that they feel
better like their autoimmune diseases
clear up their allergies clear up so
what is going on there well what if you
were to type unfermented fiber okay like
maybe overloading the gut with so much
fiber that you can't digest it and some
of it's uh unfermented it's not broken
down because the way that microbes deal
with fibers they fermented so if you
were to type on that you're going to
find something really interesting you're
going to find that unfermented fiber is
inflammatory so that's probably what's
happening and the reason why that's
happening is there's some alteration in
the gut
microbiome so you just don't have enough
of the right
microbes um to deal with this fiber if
you were like me in practice you have a
lot of experience working with people
oneon-one with with fiber without fiber
and the history of maybe when they start
developing inflammation and there's
always a time frame in their life that
all of a sudden they they can't digest
this or all of a sudden they stting
having inflammation and so it's really
important to do a history on what that
person consumed before that whether they
developed an allergy as a child or late
in life for me I can get away with
eating anything until I was in my 20s so
if you start asking questions about
someone's past about what they ate and
what would alter the microbes you get
some really interesting information we
know uh antibiotics destroy your
microbes right like 80% of your microbes
they like they die off so people who
have had a lot of antibiotics have a lot
of gut inflammation they have more
autoimmune they have more allergies and
also when an infant is fed have they had
breast milk which is loaded with
probotics from birth and a lot of other
things to build the immune system so I
think a lot of these inflammatory
problems start early on as a child and
if we look at what kids eat uh it's a
lot of ultra processed foods AKA junk
Foods could this be the source of that
we have salt we don't have a lot of
fiber we have sugar we have different
forms of sugar we have different forms
of flour we have different oils maybe
it's a combination of all all these
right here right and it's so funny that
they call it alra processed food because
it doesn't even resemble food but before
I go any further I want to share
something about Ultra processed food
companies this is a little short story
but I wanted to tell you a little bit
about the tobacco industry these
companies uh got to a point where there
was just too much mounting evidence that
proves that smoking is bad for you in
December 1953 the CEOs from five uh
tobacco companies met together at a
hotel and they came up with a strategy
to counter this they formed the tobacco
industry research committee to control
the science and they focused on creating
doubt they said as long as doubt and
controversy prevailed the industry could
fight off regulations because it is the
best means of competing with a body of
facts that exist in the general public
it is also the means of establishing a
controversy but what's even more
interesting between 1988 and
2001 certain tobacco companies uh owned
craft General Foods in Nabisco so
apparently a lot of the ultra processed
food companies adopted some of these
tactics as well I mean if you even look
at the time frame between the 80s and
now I mean obesity has tripled kids are
developing diabetes there's conflict of
interest with the scientific acmis and
advisory committees that form our food
pyramid there was an investigation in
2002 into the dietician organization
and um found that they were investing in
stocks in Nestle pepsicola Johnson and
Johnson so there's a lot of conflict of
interests but the alter processed food
companies have created a lot of doubt
and uncertainty into the public they
blame the individual not the food they
attack the scientist to uh speak out
they emphasize and promote physical
activity over the diet they deny the
existence of harmful foods saying
there's no bad food it's just bad
choices and they have an endless call
for we need more research because it's
inconclusive so in other words there's a
lot of corruption in this area of alra
processed food and one thing that's very
interesting about alra processed food is
that there's a high level of
glyphosate it's in the corn it's in the
soy it's in the cotton seed oil canola
oils it's in the wheat products it's
sprayed on the wheat did you know that
glyphosate is also classified in even
patented as an antibiotic glyphosate
inhibits
lactobacillus and bifido bacteria two
main strains of gut bacteria and out of
all the antibiotics that uh humans have
taken because the widely promoted in
Soul glyphosate this is the main
antibiotic that's being put into our
food and very unfortunately we've been
put on an antibiotic without even
knowing it and so out of all the
combinations of these ingredients
glyphosate is at the top of the list as
far as of what it does to our microbiome
now in Plants what it does is it kills
bacteria okay in the soil and then it
allows the unfriendly bacteria to
overgrow in Kill the plant in fact in
this one report that I read if you spray
glyphosate in the sterile soil where
there's no bacteria apparently it
doesn't kill the plant in other words
you have to strengthen the pathogens by
getting rid of defense mechanism so it
can take over the plant I wonder if this
is happening to our guts right now
especially since autoimmune diseases and
many allergies start at the gut and if
we've been on an antibiotic for all
these years what is that doing to our
inflammation so as soon as we create
enough damage in the gut now we can't
handle the fiber why because the
microbes aren't correct and we're going
to get unfermented fiber and it's going
to irritate us and this is is why um
people that go on a carnivore diet do
much much better and then when you
change a child's diet and get them off
the ultra processed foods right they
start having all sorts of positive
outcomes so the number one most
inflammatory food on the planet is this
right here Ultra processed foods which
is more than one but it's a basic recipe
of sugar flour and Seed oils with
glyphosate all right so now that you
know the most inflamm
food if you haven't seen my video on the
most anti-inflammatory food that's a
very interesting one too I'm going to
put that right here check it
out